in the world's largest refugee camp in
Bangladesh life for women and children
is particularly difficult this woman
fled from Myanmar with her three
children and husband after their village
was burnt down two years ago my husband
left me and my children after we came
here and it was difficult for me to make
ends meet I didn't have any other option
any other option that is then to work as
a prostitute now when she gets the call
she travels to the neighboring towns
outside of the refugee camps there's no
other job I can do I can't do anything
else
if I remarry my new husband would take
care of me but not my children it's
impossible to say how many Ranga
refugees end up in the sex trade here
many are as young as 14 according to a
local NGO thousands of women are
trafficked across Bangladesh and even
abroad lured by false promises of jobs
and a marriage
we wanted to gauge how widespread the
problem really is in the tourist town of
Cox Bazar roughly forty kilometers from
the camps we got in touch with a pimp
who boasted to have several Ranga women
on corn hello I'll show you some girls
and if you like them you can take them
if not you can leave a bit later our
reporter meets the man at a pre-arranged
point and gets into an auto rickshaw
with him while we follow behind our
reporters secretly filming the entire
encounter first stop is a hotel which
serves as a brothel to begin with the
manager seemed suspicious and denies
having any prostitutes then he shows us
pictures of a few women on his phone
none of them seemed to be Ranga around
10 p.m. the pimp sends a real woman to
our hotel she's too scared to talk to us
when we reveal were journalists because
she's worried the hotel might tell the
pimps but she confirms she is a 23 year
old rahega refugee she says she's a
victim of her circumstances
back at the camp
the sex worker we met earlier tells us
three Inga are not allowed to work and
there have been several police raids on
hotels doubling as brothels she herself
was recently released from jail if I
can't find any other way to make money
I'll have to go back to this work if I
do I might get arrested again
but she's likely to take that risk again
because for now she doesn't have a
choice and faced with such a bleak
future Ranga women remain easy prey for
the pimps and traffickers and we are
joined now by DW Zara fatal Islam he's
one of the reporters that you saw there
in that piece and he also happens to be
from Bangladesh and you know we saw in
that report one of the RO hinge Oh women
essentially saying she has no other
choice she has to make money how
desperate is the situation there the
situation is quite desperate there
because you know the most of the
refugees who came from Myanmar in 2017
are women and children so they are big
in number and they want to get involved
with job opportunities always to earn
something so that they can meet or they
can make and meets but there is not much
opportunity for them apart from
providing relief by NGOs and
international aid agencies surely the
Bangladeshi authorities are aware of the
situation what was your experience I'm
in interacting with them how are they
dealing with it I was there two years
ago and that time I saw that there is a
welcoming attitude towards throwing us
in Bangladesh but what happened last
time when I was there with two of my
colleagues I saw that there is a
repatriation at him going on and it
totally failed and then the Foreign
Minister responded very angrily angrily
saying that we have to reduce their I
mean benefits or things they're getting
there so we have to make something so
that they agree to return at some point
so now the situation is more like one of
this government wants to get rid of them
they don't want to
provide any kind of support to rowing us
because they the government doesn't
recognize rowing us as refugees and when
they don't recognize as refugees they
don't get any benefits that refugees
should get according to an international
law so there are no other alternatives
for these women they don't have because
there is no other employment
opportunities or anything I mean
personally I think there should have
some kind of opportunities for our girls
can work women can work and earn
something out of it because they have
time they're kind of living in you know
worked out at camp but not many
opportunities to spend time not many
opportunities to earn something to work
so there should be some opportunities by
the government of Bangladesh or
especially for women in their camp and I
imagine that many of these you know
people they those were hinges they they
don't want to go back to Myanmar
especially given how they were forced
out of the country yeah well we talked
to many of the refugees and we asked
this specific question whether they want
to return or not what we found that they
want to return and that's why they are
staying near the border area but they
have some specific demands that they
want to Myanmar government to recognize
them as Rohingya to provide them
citizenship of Myanmar also they want
safety and security in Rakhine region so
if these are provided these are insured
then they are willingly interested in
returning to Myanmar the country they
think they belong to GWS are a photo
islam thank you so much for your
reporting